now at five a new variant of the
coronavirus is detected
right here in clark county but
researchers tell us they found it first
in what we
flush good evening to you at five i'm
brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez different
mutations of the coronavirus mean the
virus is now adapting
and our eye team confirming this new
variant is circulating right now
david charns here now with the important
details and also what it's called david
well denise this isn't the variant the
delta variant we've reported on for the
past couple of weeks but an entirely new
one
farther down the greek alphabet is
lambda and that's where we get this new
lambda variant the strain originated in
peru
and makes up the majority of cases in
south america
now these variants are being found first
in our wastewater through this though
the state lab that is confirms one case
from june now earlier this year the
i-team showed you scientists are
analyzing what we flush
actually finding the virus and then the
subsequent variants basically
catching the spread before we see it in
real time it can take a few weeks for
samples from the covid test many of us
have taken
to catch up with what scientists are
finding in the sewer
the researcher who runs the lab over at
unlv says reopening
is simply leading to more spread
in some ways i'm not entirely surprised
given
that travel is going back to where it
was
right so we're going to be seeing people
move around with
different strains now researchers in
england where this variant was
first detected a couple of weeks ago say
the vaccine appears to be
an effective way to fight the lambda
variant and case numbers show well
cases are up here in southern nevada
vaccines are working
the majority of people hospitalized
right now are not
vaccinated now state health leaders also
tell us they expect
that more cases of these variants are
actually happening than
what we're seeing simply because the
samples that are getting tested are just
a portion
of the cases we see the best protection
they say
is simply get vaccinated i'm david
charns 8 news now